fantastic beasts and where to find them
has more deleted scenes than any of the
Harry Potter movies according to
producer David Heyman yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers it's Jan here and I'm going
to talk about some of the deleted scenes
that didn't make it into the first
fantastic beast movie here as well as
some other things we can look forward to
in the Fantastic peace sequel of course
I'll be talking spoilers so if you're
not ready for those check out my spoiler
free review of fantastic beasts here now
do you remember that little wisp of the
obscurus that drifts up and out of the
subway after the final battle well
although the Aurore sort they destroyed
the obscuri all it was definitely a hint
that we haven't seen the last of Cruden
spur bone and there's actually a deleted
scene that would have made his setup
four fantastic beasts - a lot more
obvious in that scene credence boards a
boat and it seems like it might have
been the one that Newt was getting on at
the end of the movie producer David
Heyman has said that they didn't want to
make the setup of Creedence for the next
movie so obvious but it feels like this
could have been a really good
post-credit stinger a theme cut early on
in the movie featured Jacob and his
girlfriend before he met Queenie
the scene had Jacob returning from the
bank to the street where he lives to
find his girlfriend waiting for him
director David Yates explained this in
the deleted scene she runs down the
street and asked Jacob how did it go did
you get your loan when Jacob replies
that the bank didn't give it to him she
takes off her engagement ring and leaves
him JK Rowling originally wanted the
scene cut from the final script but
Yates insisted on filming it as he
thought it would be a touching moment
Yates said it was cut in the end because
it was no longer needed to help the
audience empathize with Jacob by that
point there's a really wonderful
cutscene which was teased in one of the
trailers the snippet we did see in the
trailer is with Jacob and Newt who are
sat down in newts menagerie smiling and
applauding with Jacob saying I want to
be a wizard this was part of a much
longer scene in which Queenie and Tina
sing the ilver Morni school song as part
of the discussion that Newt Tina and
Queenie are having about whether
Hogwarts or al-hammoury is a better
Wizarding school Alison sudol who plays
Queenie is a singer as well as an
actress and she wrote the song which
both she and Katherine Waterston sank
unfortunately it slowed down the
momentum of the film and was Kurt but
David Yates has promised it will appear
on the blu-ray and DVD extras
originally there was an extended version
of the scene at the department store
while Jacob and Queenie were trying to
catch the deme guys which is charging
around the store it tramples over Jacob
who grabs onto the creature we then see
Jacob getting dragged around by
something that's invisible Dan Fogler
who plays Jacob has said the moment is
reminiscent of how Indiana Jones gets
pulled around behind a truck in Raiders
of the Lost Ark the deleted scene
finishes with a slapstick moment as the
deme guys suddenly goes around a corner
sending Jacob crashing into a clothing
display and as Queenie runs over to
check if he's okay Jacob pulls on a hat
and smiles as if nothing had happened
Eddie Redmayne who plays Newt Scamander
has revealed that there was a shirtless
scene that he had to spend 7 months
working out for but it ended up being
deleted from the final film
JK Rowling had written in the script
that Newt needed to be buff in the scene
which showed him going into his
briefcase and down into his menagerie
when he pulled off his shirt revealing
numerous war wounds and scars so those
are some of the scenes that were cut
from the theatrical release of fantastic
beasts but what do we know about what we
can look forward to in the fantastic
beasts sequel well there are going to be
four more movies in the fantastic beasts
franchise each one set in a different
City the five movies take place over a
period of 19 years with the first film
starting in 1926 and the saga ending in
1945
now 1945 marks the year that Dumbledore
and Grimble vault had their epic battle
that ends a global Wizarding war we
already got the reveal of Grendel vaults
at the end of this movie with a short
cameo by Johnny Depp and a young
Dumbledore has been confirmed to appear
in the sequel although at this point
casting hasn't been confirmed Dumbledore
was born in 1881 so the actor playing
him could well be in his late 40s who
would you like to see playing a young
Dumbledore in the sequels another
storyline was teased for the sequel
thanks to the mention of lesser
Lestrange midway through the film and
again at the end when Tina asked mute
more about the strange and he seemed to
be rather evasive in his answers
divergent series stars zoe kravitz has
already been cast as letter Lestrange
and is confirmed to appear in fantastic
beast 2 it will be interesting to see
how her character ties in with the
Lestrange family from harry potter and
also with the reveal and the cursed
child that Bellatrix Lestrange
mother of Voldemort's child there was
also an interesting tease that Jacob may
not have been completely obliviated at
the end the movie after Queenie kissed
him and shielded him with her magic
umbrella after he stepped out into the
rain after all he seemed to recognize
her when he saw her in his bakery where
he'd made lots of cakes in the shape of
the fantastic beasts Dan Fogler the
actor who plays jacob has hinted that
his character has likely been affected
by all the magic he's been in contact
with such as being bitten by a merc lap
eating magical strudel and being treated
with newts potions and although newts
Tina Queenie and Jacob are all confirmed
to appear in the next movie producer
David Heyman believes that they may not
be at the heart of all the movies in
fact it seems that in the next film it
will actually be Creedence in Grindle
vault who will be the main players all
of this means that it looks like in the
sequel we're going to be getting more
emphasis on building the struggle
between Dumbledore and Grendel vault
it's going to be more like the Harry vs.
Voldemort conflicts from the Harry
Potter franchise
so although the beasts will be taking
something of a backseat in the sequel
director David Yates has confirmed that
they are planning on introducing some
new ones including a particularly
special Chinese fantastic beast so guys
what do you think about the deleted
scenes and do you think any of them
should have been in the movie and what
would you like to see happen in the
sequel do let me know in the comments
below if you enjoy finding out about
deleted scenes for movies you love then
check out my full playlist below or you
can also watch the full fantastic beasts
press conference with JK Rowling and the
cast below - as always if you enjoyed
this please do like share and subscribe
for more videos like this one thanks for
watching and see you next time you'll be
going movie lovers